so just as dc was finally starting to
produce some really really good content
with shows like peacemaker and movies
like the batman and upcoming exciting
projects like black adam
warner brothers goes and merges with
discovery now being called warner bros
discovery and apparently some big
changes are coming to dc it sounds like
dc is actually looking for their own
kevin feige type of figure to run things
over at dc now marvel studios has
obviously been crushing it kevin feige
is definitely the one to get credit
there's a lot of people involved but we
know that kevin feige's at the helm does
it make sense for dc to have somebody
like this or could this be a bad idea
depending on your views this could be a
really good thing for dc or it could be
a really bad thing for to see now
variety released an article that has
exclusive details about what dc is
thinking and apparently
it could get a complete
overhaul
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder we
normally talk marvel but i love dc too
and this is some pretty big news so
let's go over this article and talk
about what exactly this means now it
starts off by saying the new owners of
all things batman superman and wonder
woman are exploring an overhaul of dc
entertainment it says before the merger
closed zazlav who is the ceo now vetted
candidates with experience in creating
and nurturing blockbuster intellectual
property with the goal of potentially
finding someone to serve as a creative
and strategic czar similar to what
marvel has in kevin feige now right away
people have kind of been making this
comparison for a pretty long time now
people have been saying dc needs
somebody like kevin feige that is in
charge of everything somebody who has a
vision but right off the bat here's the
thing about kevin feige
he's a huge comic book fan
he really is into everything that he
does and i think the problem with dc has
been is that it's really been run by a
company it's been ran by a lot of
different people throwing a lot of
different suggestions out there and i
think the success that they found
recently was letting people kind of do
their own thing having these directors
come in and these writers come in like
james gunn go this is what i got from
the comics i'm a screenwriter i'm a
developer i produce things i know what
to do just let me do it they let them do
it and then magic happens like the
peacemaker show which was fantastic the
article continues to say insiders say
that zaslav believes that the success of
the merger one that has left the company
highly leveraged will rest in no small
part on unlocking the potential of dc
comics universe of characters discovery
insiders believe that although dc has
achieved cinematic success with recent
films such as aquaman and the batman it
lacks a coherent creative and brand
strategy discovery believes that several
top shelf characters such as superman
have been left to languish and need to
be revitalized they also believe that
projects like todd phillips's joker are
a shining example of how second build
characters from dc library can and
should be exploited margot robbie's
harley quinn is another example now
he's not wrong here what he says is it
lacks coherent creative and brand
strategy and i think this was kind of
the problem the strategy kind of seemed
like it was all over the place now
what's really sad is it seems like some
future projects might actually be
affected by this when the flash it was
kind of supposed to explain everything
that dc had under their belts it was
supposed to show us what the plan was
how everything kind of operated now
not everything needs to be a marvel
cinematic universe i think one off
things like the batman and the joker or
joker
i think one-off things like the batman
and joker they work and they kind of
work because they are one-off yes you
can create other universes within these
projects like gotham city police show
that's coming out you can create other
things within that universe but not
everything has to be connected i think
these films worked because they weren't
but then you have things like the
suicide squad and the spin-off the
peacemaker series that they also work as
well i don't think they need to be
copying marvel but i do think they do
need to hone in on a better plan but dc
isn't exactly the best at making good
judgment calls for comic book characters
and i think that's because the people
who are behind all decisions aren't
exactly true comic book fans like i said
kevin feige he's deep in the comments he
kevin feige he's deep in the comics he's
read all of these comics he knows what
he's talking about he knows how to make
everything work so i do kind of agree
with what they're talking about here
they should have somebody come in but
unless that person is pretty much
exactly like kevin feige but with dc
comics i don't think that it's going to
work i think the only other option is
you bring in people for projects that
are like that like i mentioned before
james gunn zack snyder these worked the
fandom really does enjoy the films that
these people make i think if they wanted
to go that route it might actually be
better for them now it seems like they
have always lacked a brand strategy now
when they first came out with the
justice league it almost seemed like
they were trying to be different than
marvel like very very obviously
blatantly different than marvel marvel
started off by introducing these
characters they put them all in a
universe where they exist and then they
brought them together they came in to
the avengers not knowing each other kind
of have an idea of who they are because
they existed in the same universe and
then they worked together then they kept
doing their own thing then they brought
them back together dc went and did the
opposite they brought everybody together
with without really introducing anybody
and then they went let's now do like
their own things it's something that
could have worked if they had a better
idea of what they really wanted to do
and unfortunately i think they just
really didn't know at the time now the
biggest thing here is that i think they
want a connected universe but i don't
think they have to do that like i
mentioned i think they should go kind of
twofold here i think they should
continue to make their one-off projects
because i think those projects are
really really good i really like the
one-off projects and i think if they
continue to do that they will have a lot
of success and they will make good films
however i do like the idea of having a
connected universe it doesn't have to be
on as big of a scale that marvel does it
but it can be connected because let's
face it we all love to see batman
interact with superman with wonder woman
we love to see all of that
now the article goes on to say that one
insider suggested that zaslov was less
interested in finding a creative guru
and more eager to hire someone who had
the type of business background needed
to keep all the different factions of dc
working more harmoniously
that could work again i don't think they
have to choose between either or i think
they could do both but this could
definitely work because they definitely
seem to lack harmony between all of
their properties most of the time people
don't even know what dc is doing
they put so many projects out there and
some are connected and some are but also
are in some weird way at the same time
they have multiple different jokers
going on right now there's multiple
different versions of some characters
it's just kind of a mess right now and
again the flash was supposed to kind of
explain everything and i think the flash
can do a very good job at setting up dc
for a very successful future because
they are introducing a multiverse and
that opens up a lot of different
possibilities and it also makes it to
where everything can be connected
without having to really be connected
that's the cool thing about the
multiverse kind of anything is possible
but the big question is right now who
exactly do they need to come in what can
they actually get from somebody
overlooking everything one i do think
they need this person but only if it's
the right person and two i do think this
person needs to realize that everything
can exist in a large multiverse but
still be one off i think that is going
to be a key to the success of dc because
they can't copy marvel studios
everyone's just going to compare it and
don't get me wrong i love dc characters
batman is actually my favorite superhero
as much as i talk about marvel batman is
my favorite but what do you think dc
actually needs at this point in time do
you think they need a kevin feige type
person or do you think they need to
bring in people like james gunn and zack
snyder and just kind of let them do
their thing let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
are you a fan of dc and if you are do
you like how things are going so far or
do you think they actually need this
overhaul let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]